just remember what the question is okay
you had this forty 7585 triangle right
which when you divide everything through
by your common factor which is common
factor five okay you can see it's an
eight fifteen seventeen path the growing
triad one of my favorites it's very nice
I taught that team also nice but three
four five it's too mainstream you know
so so this is why people often don't
spot it like you know immediately okay
so there's my right angle now
you can see you have to situate this
semicircle you want to get the maximum
area which really means the maximum
radius for your semicircle and you've
got to use one of the signs to form part
of the diameter all of the diameter so
you can obviously see this is not the
biggest circle semicircle that I can
skip because I have a longest side I can
choose over here but to find the area of
this the method I'm going to use it will
help you work out the areas that you're
getting okay so I've labeled a little
bit this year which I've put with a dot
is the center of the semicircle which is
not the same as the center of AC right
because if it were the circle would come
out here it would go outside the
triangle yeah so this is the center of
the circle that a colleague boat now
what we really want to work out is the
young the dimensions this radius right
like this this distance you if I can
work out that radius then I've got the
area in the back so let's just call that
radius R for radius okay now it's forty
seventy five eighty five okay so this
must be my seventy-five and this must be
my 85 okay now my shortest side here is
40 but rather than like have lots of
confusing information on there I'm just
going to add on the remainder of this
side a or what is a earn if AC is 40 and
OC is ah this is gonna be the difference
is it not forty take off all right okay
so what can I use to work this out I
don't have much to grapple with here in
order to like this out I've got to get a
relationship between these two okay so
this is the big clue right I'm gonna put
an extra construct
here on top of the semicircle I'm gonna
put in this construction okay now I'll
call this point I'll call it be the
point okay now it's on the circumference
and critically it's where it hits a be
right the semi circle intersect its
tangent to a B it hits just once because
if it doesn't hit at all then I can make
a bigger semicircle and if it's twice
I've gone outside so I have to get once
now have a look at this this triangle
are made up here a or a P you can almost
even see it what kind of triangle is it
it's a special triangle right I've drawn
my diagram well enough that you can see
it's a right angle now you don't need to
just look rely on the awesomeness of my
diagram to know it's a right angle what
piece of information do you know that
tells you this right angle very good
this is a radius appears or radius
hey B is a tangent and as we established
a couple lessons ago the radius sorry
the tangent is perpendicular to the
radius to the point of contact so I have
a right angle there ready we're here
right angle here so you tell me what's
the relationship between triangle a opie
and our original triangle a B C what's
the relationship they clearly similar
aren't they they both have a right angle
and in fact this angle in the corner OAP
is common to both triangles it's in a
little triangle and of course it's in
the big triangle right so these two are
similar to each other so what I I want I
want lengths donate okay so which sides
can I compare one to another
well the easiest one to compare is that
this Saiki a o in my little triangle AR
is the hypotenuse is it not it's the
longer side it's opposite the right
angle what side does that correspond to
in the big one that's a B right so I can
compare I can say the ratio between this
hypotenuse and the other hypotenuse or
to be equal to now
you can choose what kind of side would
you choose - what parasite could you
choose to compare to get you some useful
information ap what's AP it's up don't
know you don't have enough information
like it's less than a five o'clock
clearly but you don't know how much less
you have nothing about that okay on the
other hand you know exactly words equal
to right what's it equals it's the
radius Saints its radius right so
therefore for t minus R is the
hypotenuse of the small triangle R is
another side a small triangle what does
it correspond to does it correspond to
the longer non hypotenuse or the shorter
non hypotenuse how would you be able to
tell how can we actually work out what
features do you use to tell whether it's
this one or this one then you take it so
I've got the right angle right I have
noticed that this is the side opposite
the right angle in the small triangle
and this is the side opposite the right
angle in the big triangle character I'll
make a suggestion
good let's let me be a little more final
that over P that side which happens to
equal R it's opposite the marked angle
right so therefore what it must
correspond to in the small triangle must
be the side opposite this angle in the
big triangle does that make sense do you
see why I actually didn't do it in this
case but why we make a big deal about
corresponding sides and angles on our
company you match these up so you can
match these up and not mark it up this
is going to be 75 okay do you need me to
show you what to do from there you can
get off of this can't you let's just
quickly rehearse it together what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna multiply across right
seventy five by forty five by forty
three thousand three thousand minus 75
all right eighty-five
now what I'll take this over the other
side okay so before I do that I might as
well divide through by some number make
it easy for me like say 5 that'll make
this 600 that'll make this 15 that'll
make this 17 a little bit better isn't
it okay add that 50 over here that's
gonna be 32 I'm all right
okay what can I do here mm or you could
just go that that's got a bit of a fun
number
what's it equal to what do you get I'm
thinking I'm getting 18.75
can you verify that for me yep there you
go there's a radius now it is clearly
not the biggest radius or the biggest
semicircle I can fit but here's one and
you can see the way that I did it
okay I wonder if you can use this tool
to try to work out what is the biggest
semicircle the smallest semicircle the
smallest biggest semicircle is on this
side and the reason why is because
that's the smallest side that's x40
right so clearly if I'm building it off
of the 75 side I can get something
bigger and this is what I get
right so I compare ah right which is
opposite the arm the common angle with
40 because that's also opposite the
comment angle just in the big one right
arodd40 is 75 minus R that's the
hypotenuse over 85 the other hypotenuse
yeah okay then I cancel out a factor of
five multiply cost and that's my radius
okay so that's a significant improvement
on 18.75
as you can see but logic does tell us
that using the very longest side will
get us better results okay so how do we
actually work out like all of the
distances here again there's a single
construction that you need that will
help you hmm
every time I'm taking advantage of this
fact that the tangents perpendicular to
the radius right here I have two choices
right I'm tangent to both sides do you
see that change it to both sides so
actually in some senses I could use
either one to keep the numbers smaller
I'm gonna go over there
okay so I must be at my angles to that
bear which creates a right angle
triangle in the top this is ah yep I've
already got this side over here the 75
okay but to do some comparisons right I
need to know like two lengths in this
triangle just like I've got two legs
oh and 75 minus R right so I have to
choose yeah if this is our I've got to
be able right now this side or this side
which do you think would be easier do
you need the hypotenuse should be easy
to work out or that vertical sign the
vertical side is easier but how am I
going to do it because I know that the
whole thing is 40 right but I I don't
know what the pieces are or do i this is
extra information on here that will help
you right remember we said that n is
perpendicular to the radius so this is a
bad mood I try my best
it's quite hard to do this accurate if
you're an accomplice you obviously do a
much better job but there's a right
angle happening down here right and
that's also the radius radius radius
which means this little part in here in
the small round travel I made of course
is 40 take all right so I've got 40 it's
going along here so now I can do my
comparison okay
in the sport triangle ah that's the
longer normai potenuse side so it should
be 75 yep I compare it to the vertical
one that's 40 take are on the shorter
not hypotenuse images what do you write
are you satisfied with that statement
let's get rid of our factor of 5 that'll
become 15 that'll become 8 yeah yeah
so now let's see let's cross multiply so
I'm going to get 8r over here what am I
going to get on the right-hand side 15
by 40
600 minus 15 so I just need to add a
Guinness 23 so therefore and this is how
I could so easily tell if you had the
right answer or not 23 is prime so you
can't simplify this fraction down any
further it happens it should be
approximately if I'm right 26.0 ago in
Excel check yeah which is why I had to
laugh when someone by measurement found
26 right
you're never gonna measure you're never
gonna measure that point 0 9 with your
instruments unless you have an enormous
diagram right 26 point zero nine okay
and look at this this is just as simple
it turns arithmetic as whoops he adds up
any of the other semicircles we made but
it's harder to see it's hard to see you
requires some real work in this triangle